the world champion u.s. women's soccer
team will celebrate from coast to coast
today but here in New York City we're
hosting a ticker tape parade to honor
the team's World Cup win before the
players fly to Los Angeles they've got
an event there tonight called the ESPYs
CTM national correspondent Jericka
Duncan is up the parade starting point
that's in lower Manhattan Eureka good
morning all I know is the city is
psyched and ready yes we are and it's
deja vu I remember covering the Women's
World Cup four years ago right now it's
still a little quiet but there are some
floats that are being set up here behind
me about ten that we counted and we've
noticed a small crowd gathering where
the players will get on these floats
within the last half hour but remember
the parade is still just over two hours
away it will start here at Battery Park
and travel along the canyon of heros
route it's an historic parade route a
Broadway that's hosted notable figures
such as Nelson Mandela and even players
from the New York Yankees the parade
will end at City Hall where Mayor Bill
DeBlasio will award these women with
keys to the city crews have of course
been preparing for this with a ton of
shredded recycled paper to serve as
confetti for the ticker-tape tradition
that will be thrown from the businesses
and homes along the route now the team
arrived in the u.s. from France on
Monday and the city has been preparing
for these champions parts of lower
Manhattan will literally be shut down to
celebrate the team it's their second
consecutive World Championship when in
fourth since the competition started in
1991 a lot of controversy as we know
watching and covering this world cup but
celebration it's all about celebration
Rodriguez thank you very much